foreign
let's go to Panama City and talk to
Connor what's up Connor how we doing
hey John thank you Jenna and the rest of
the team for taking my call today how
are you doing I'm doing outstanding and
uh I appreciate you being on the show
man so what's up how can I help yeah
yeah yes I guess I want to start it off
with a little bit of background on this
one so Ken and I had a conversation last
week the question I'm going to ask you
kind of stem from the conversation he
and I had over employer issues that I'm
having now
um really is um flexibility on my work
schedule in a little bit and then uh
positional limitations for growth uh
promotion things like that that have
been happening over the last few months
ever since we've had some turnover
organization so bottom line I'm helping
raise a child that's not mine
genetically or adoptively but I do have
some in local parental stuff against it
so I do have some responsibility wise
and legal scale for her why a little bit
of background on that situation yeah
this Max fiance's child and so her and I
are not together I'm kind of doing a
single parent Duty thing over here the
girls one and a half and she's adorable
lover to death but my employers have had
some issues with me let me stop right
there let me stop right there why are
you involved at all in this
so her and I we split up a few years ago
when we didn't see eye to eye on our
values they didn't lie and we dated for
years and uh she went up to Georgia
after we split up and got pregnant the
guy after four months of pregnancy
dipped out got out of the picture she
came back down to Florida and I found
out about it through a mutual friend of
ours and I come from a family background
to where I was raised by single parents
my mother took off when I was very young
and I know what kind of impact I can
have on a child I mean I feel like God
put me in a place now to where I'm able
to support uh both mentally and
financially for the child on my side
here but being able to have you know a
dual parent household there is awesome
even if we aren't together it's still
good to have two parent figures in my
eyes
foreign
I think you're setting everybody up for
an amount of heartbreak that is is is
going to be devastating on the Richter
scale
and here's why here's why you're playing
dad
you're performing dad
and you're not
this girl is always going to wonder why
her daddy left her
this little girl's always going to be
grateful for this man who just literally
materialized and helped with groceries
and diapers
but also allowed mom to punt the
responsibilities
of raising a kid
you're playing you're playing dead and
you're pretending to be in a family with
a woman that y'all y'all made an adult
choice we're not right for each other
and we shook hands and we parted ways
she went and got pregnant happened love
her to I don't don't have a an ill ill
will like an ounce of ill will in my
heart for her not I want the best for
her
but then you came and swooped back in
and tried to
fast forward your lives three or four or
five years
see what I'm saying like it should it
this ends in a supernova at some point
either you meet somebody she meets
somebody and he cuts you out completely
I mean the whole thing's uh in local
princess is a is a Doctrine it's not law
right it's it's in place of the parent
it's it's I don't know this this whole
thing feels like man it's about to get
real real messy
tell me I'm crazy be like hey you're an
idiot you don't actually know
I mean you're spot on with that and
that's really been my concern from since
the beginning of all this but I've been
in her license before she was born I
mean I drove in South Carolina when I
was at work there on part-time uniform
full-time Federal contractors so I was
up there in South Carolina for work for
a while came down for her birth I was
here so I mean I'm like she's I'm dad to
her and in my eyes she's my daughter but
we're having issues but but you're not
figure out the father situation in
Georgia and all that I know but you're
not
and you're not with her mom
yeah we try to make it work but of
course the values didn't know it's not
going to work yeah
and so the the
man you have one of the best hearts I've
ever met
but it's it's being applied in a way
that is going to be so
it's just I just don't see a way this
plays out
yeah and that's always been inking in
the back of my heart to something that's
really concerned me and really something
that's added an extra strain and stress
and I mean my employer is now adding to
that portion to you by making my life
harder here in the office by not
accommodating me on certain things with
taking care of her when I get sick she
gets sick child care dropping off a
daycare in the morning so that they're
under the premise of well this is not
your child you have a responsibility so
I mean they're taking off work these
times and you don't have to
I see their point it's not your kid
um and the other side of it is if you
want to continue pretending she's your
kid you're gonna have to find a that's
on you to find a place that's going to
be flexible in that way
huh
and it would be cool if they were just
like hey do you're growing up do
whatever you want to do
um I just don't I
or on the occasion you want to take you
know like I'm gonna take my neighbor's
kid in because my neighbor's kid's sick
and my neighbors got to work but like
I'm just being a great neighbor right
that's that's that's something but all
the time
man that's tough
yeah and it's one of those things where
it's not a huge like it's not affecting
my workplace performance any on this
side currently but it's just the whole
dynamic of the situation and they know
about it they know my past with the
mother and the kind of the situation
they don't agree with that on their side
so they're not really accommodating
anything on that hand which they have
the right to do and I know it's one of
those things where it's
I want what's best for the child at the
end of the day and it's one of those
things that's heavy in my heart because
I've waited so long the point where I'm
now attached and now other issues
starting to span from it but now it's
like a decision Factor has to be played
when she's a year and a half I mean she
won't know the difference right now so
just think of me as some guy who's may
not even know me years for now I've
already have that but I'll tell you this
um I think I've talked about on the show
before I I think my son was two and a
half or three I have to go back and see
maybe four I don't know he's older than
a maybe four
um my wife uh was doing some Consulting
in right outside of Sao Paulo Brazil so
they paid for us to fly in so my son and
I just took like a 14-day trip maybe
it's 12 days oh we were just there
forever and it was just me and him
hanging out catching two I mean not
catching but like two cans were landing
and we were eating mangoes and avocados
like off a tree just in a yard and it
was amazing Road donkeys he remembers
zero none zero and I mean I thought Nick
we made this super chicken nun zero yeah
he has no memory at all and I tell you
that like
um there will the the the
biological psychological emotional
spiritual consequence that machine is
already emotion
her dad left her gone disappeared
and I'll tell you this he might show
just show right back up
and you might not who knows
yeah but he she she's one and a half
your ex-fiancee
uh I mean
like let me just ask you a hard question
man like what are you like why are you
doing this
is it because were you jealous that that
somebody else got her pregnant like why
why what brought you back into this it
really wasn't that it's more from I
guess my past experience is really kind
of went round circle and I saw an
opportunity for me to be in a child's
life and make a huge difference on her
mentally physically spiritually
emotionally you know being there as dad
has always been something that I wanted
to do and wanted to have and I just I
thought this was a God thing to bring it
back in my life and maybe it was one of
those deceitful things that I thought
was a God thing but it was a mean thing
acting irrationally you know it it I
knew the dynamic was going to be hard I
just I didn't expect myself to go
through this amount of turmoil this
early on and it's not a mental turmoil
to stand somewhere I have an issue with
the child or the issue with her mother
it's now like other things in my life
was getting started to get impacted by
it when I mean in reality it shouldn't
be an issue but it's just they know it
to be not with an example they think
would be right for me to do and good for
me and they're looking out for me my
life harder to try to almost force me
into making a decision
well I
I don't know that your employers got
that responsibility that that to me that
responsibility lays on my close friends
and people who I've given permission my
mentors who I've given permission to
hold me accountable for things
yeah they've been treating me like a
child a lot here and that's really
wondering elsewhere as well because
they've been limiting my growth
potential on my age well those guys I
work with yeah I've been an organization
seven years I'm 26 started now I was 19.
and all the guys I work with they're I
mean my boss about to retire he's 62
like the average age is 46 50 more
organizations it's an Air Force command
so we're in charge of Air Force forces
in the United States so it's a pretty
good response it's a pretty big
responsibility and a big job but I've
demonstrated myself performance Wise
It's just yeah I don't agree with
everything going on outside but
leadership is more than performance
leadership's also wisdom
yeah
leadership is wisdom
and there was nothing that made me more
enraged when I was 26 year old associate
dean of students that thought I knew
everything and people told me I wasn't
ready yet that phrase made me so enraged
until I became the chief student affairs
officer and I thought oh my gosh I was
not ready
the only the only perspective I had was
15 years later
right
I can't imagine how infuriating that is
to hear for me to say that so let me
just say like I get that right and
there's going to be a whole Spade of
YouTube 26 year olds who are like I'm
ready fine what I'm not gonna argue that
but I like
here's what I always want to keep in
mind
and this is right wrong or indifferent
but this is just how I choose to
navigate the world
um somewhat optimistically in an
obnoxious way
your bosses have a responsibility to
maximize profits they're a for-profit
company correct
uh we're the Air Force so not really yes
you're in the Air Force okay okay well
I'm Federal Contracting here full-time
I'm part-time uniform International
Guard but I've been a contractor down
here in Florida for several years so his
contract is it a civilian contract
yeah civilian contract okay their job is
to what make money right
yep yes
um they are going to put the people in
the position that's going to help them
best make the most money
now there's politics in every job
there's people who are idiots and have
stupid Egos and all that stuff I know
that exists but I tend to operate just
because it cleans my life up
if they don't promote me it's because
they thought I couldn't I wasn't the
person that would maximize the culture
here that would maximize profit here
that would maximize customer relations
here
and if it's nefarious or I think I'm the
right guy then I'm gonna go somewhere
else
and I've been doing that since October
I've been looking around applying one of
those frustration points where I've been
through a multiple job opportunities
multiple things but oh yeah I have a
very rich field it's hard to translate
on the outside and not get very far in
his interview for all stuff but just
frustrating when like halfway to three
quarters of the way to even go into a
final interview on site yeah and then I
don't get it at that point so it's been
several jobs that's happened too
here's what I think you could really
benefit from
um
I think you need to call a licensed
mental health professional and not
because you have a mental health
disorder I don't hear that at all
but I think getting somebody that is a
neutral third party that you're
exchanging payment like I I gotta like
you would a plumber
sitting down with somebody and saying
here are some choices I'm making here
are some frustrations and challenges I'm
running into
and let them hold up a mirror next to
you because they care about you and
they're professionals right you're
paying them
yeah and say here's what I see
because here's what I see Connor I I see
somebody who is adjacent to the military
in it a little bit but adjacent to it so
you're in a limbo world
you're connected to it but through a
civilian route and that means you are
not you are kind of hierarchical but you
get you got stuck in this other lane
over here too
and man you loved this girl with all
your heart and then you all sat down and
made one of the hardest adult decisions
you're ever going to make which is I
love you and I probably always will love
you
but that doesn't mean we're right for
each other
and you'll split up
and then somebody else got your ex
fiance pregnant which would make any of
us just mad with all with every emotion
possible
you know what I mean
yeah and then you decided to try to
you're not even playing a house you're
playing divorce which is the strangest
game I've ever seen right yeah
you're playing divorce
um and you're you're it if I'm never
gonna tell if some man I'm never gonna
tell somebody he's like God's calling me
I'm never gonna fine like I I he didn't
call me he hadn't talked to me like that
but
um I'm not gonna tell you that he didn't
as an outsider it looks like you are
seeing a potential Good Deed
and you're so desperate to become the
hero in this story
that you are wallpapering over common
sense and your wallpapering over
responsibilities and accountability and
just trying to make it all right and
when I do that I run the risk of really
with my good intentions and my good
heart
causing a huge mess
if you care and love about this this
girl there's nothing to stop you from if
you want to starting your own your own
529 account for her to go to college
or creating something like there's all
kinds of ways to to participate without
pretending to be an ex the whole thing's
just confusing and messy that's why I
think it's great for you to sit down
with an adult with a an adult with a
licensed professional and say
I've dug myself quite the hole
super frustrated at work to keep
overlooking me I'm 26 years old I don't
know why but clearly they're not doing
it because they think it's fun
they're leaning on me and pressuring me
and I feel it's very very personal maybe
it is maybe it's not I don't know
and Manna created a quagmire with the
beautiful one and a half year old little
girl who I love very much but that I
have absolutely no connection to a
relationship whatsoever other than I
used to date her mom
and now I'm in a mess I need some help
and Connor
on Friday of last week I went and sat
with a counselor for two hours
the person who I think is one of the
best in
um
I I put her up against most anybody in
the United States
and I set him in a mass I need some help
it was an uncomfortable two hours but I
got a tiny little little flashlight I
hope on the back end of this thing
you're a good guy with a great heart
just need someone to help you clarify
some of the chaos and some of the mess
okay
there's a sunk cost fallacy
it's common in business when somebody
starts a business and they put five
hundred thousand dollars into it and the
business starts failing they immediately
want to say okay well I'm gonna put
another hundred thousand another hundred
thousand in it because I've already put
500 so what's 600.
I've already put 600 so what's 800.
and it's really easy to do that
relationally too
I've already been with this girl for a
year and a half this little baby what's
another 16 and a half years
I've already I've already
the great
um
the great surgeons and the great you
know Physicians of our time know when to
say okay we don't know what's happening
but nobody's getting well let's stop
let's just stop
and assess the damage and then we'll
make a new decision and that's what I
think you got to do you got to stop at
the sunk cost file so you got it's got
to pause
take a breath and look at this from 30
000 feet with somebody else by your side
I'll be here every step of the way my
brother as you sort this thing out
holler anytime but make that phone call
today and get yourself a professional
counselor you can talk to in your area
it's going to help you light the path
out of here